president biden wants to ban assault
weapons in high-capacity magazines but
he faces a steep
uphill battle in the senate cbs news has
learned the biden administration is now
exploring
options to bypass congress on gun reform
if
lawmakers do not act chief white house
correspondent nancy cordes joins us more
joins us now with more on that story
nancy here's the question
what do we know about the president's
plans what are you hearing
gail i'm told that the white house is
looking at what president biden could do
on his own but we know that legislation
is often more binding and lasts longer
than
executive action and so first the
president is calling on congress to pass
some pretty
major reforms a move that surprised even
some of his supporters
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an
hour president biden is calling for a
return to 90's era gun restrictions
we can ban assault weapons and high
capacity magazines
in this country once again it's a tall
order for a deadlocked congress that has
struggled
even to strengthen background checks
something most americans
support inaction by this congress makes
us complicit a hearing tuesday showed
that fault lines
haven't changed what happens in this
committee after every mass shooting is
democrats propose taking away guns
from law abiding citizens one big change
democrats now control the senate and the
agenda
then candidate biden promised early
action on guns
my first day of office i'm going to send
the bill to the congress
repealing repealing the liability
protection for gun manufacturers
but the issue has taken a back seat to
other major priorities
like infrastructure immigration and
covid relief
this administration could be doing
executive action
shannon watts is the founder of mom's
demand action
she says the white house has the power
on its own
to close a loophole that allows
unlicensed gun sellers
to skip a background check there isn't a
corner of the biden administration or
the justice
department that couldn't be doing
something right now to address the gun
violence crisis in this country
senate majority leader chuck schumer
vowed yesterday to put
two recently house passed gun reform
bills up for a vote in the senate
soon but it isn't clear that there are
60 votes there to pass it one democrat
west virginia's joe manchin said
yesterday that he doesn't support it
still it will force senators to go
on the record up or down on this issue
which they haven't had to do anthony
in a long time still a steep climb as
you said nancy thank you